I'll explain more at the end but let me
set up this clip in five words robot
killers Stephen Fry watch autonomous
weapons have been described as the third
revolution in warfare
after gunpowder and nuclear bombs they
could mark rapid devastating attacks on
a huge scale thousands of experts
including Elon Musk and Stephen Hawking
have signed an open letter calling for a
ban on the weapons
they say drones that can autonomously
find and eliminate people meeting
certain criteria are feasible within
years not decades but calls for a ban
have been rejected by the world's 10
largest military powers and mosque has
warned that international competition
for AI superiority is the most likely
cause of World War 3 so do we have a
recipe for disaster
let's start with the current situation
during Obama's presidency the number of
American troops in war zones dropped by
around 90 percent but there were ten
times more drone strikes Russia has
multiple unmanned drone tanks in
development and completely autonomous
armed vehicles guarding missile bases
America plans to enable its Abrams tanks
to control robotic wingman vehicles to
attack the enemy while protecting the
manned tank it is also considering a
remote-controlled version of the high
speed ripsaw vehicle air power is
already used with relative impunity and
soon the fighters will use AI to control
drone wingmen able to carry weapons test
air defenses and keep human pilots even
further from danger around the world
anti-ballistic missile defenses and
drones are diminishing nuclear
deterrence this is the US Navy's new
unmanned ship designed to hunt
submarines and launch surface weapons it
will cost around 20 thousand dollars per
day to operate compared to 700 thousand
dollars per day for a manned destroyer
in a simulation test with the Air Force
Research Lab AI drones repeatedly
defeated a human pilot
former Air Force battle manager Jean Lee
tried and failed to hit the drones and
was destroyed by them every time he said
they seemed to be aware of his
intentions and reacted instantly to his
movements and attacks autonomous weapons
would be cheap to mass-produce and may
become available to terrorists and
dictators on the black market a recent
report by the US defense Science Board
called for immediate action to
accelerate military AI development and
understand the capabilities of other
powers it also noted that commercial
drones are rapidly improving and private
AI firms are well ahead of the military
some argue a I will reduce accidental
casualties by making fewer mistakes if a
soldier believes someone is a threat
their life depends on making a quick
decision a robot on the other hand could
react to a fraction of a second before
it's fired on or even wait until it's
attacked but the weapons could also be
extremely effective at assassinations
subduing populations and selectively
killing particular ethnic groups the
second revolution in warfare brought the
world close to World War 3 with the
Cuban Missile Crisis the third
revolution may be even more volatile we
also need to plan for an even greater
threat from AI itself many experts
believe it will surpass human
intelligence in the next few decades it
may then assume full control of the
world's network weapons would you'd use
them for peacekeeping or for bringing
humanity to a quick end whether or not
humans retain control an AI arms race
may be a race to Armageddon we believe a
band that's difficult to enforce is
better than a world
flooded cheap anonymous autonomous
weapons
what do you think
[Music]
so I hope you enjoyed that clip or were
frightened by it let me know what you
thought in the comments below that clip
was actually made by friends of mine who
run a YouTube channel called pin decks
they make incredibly high quality
educational videos if you want to check
them out I will put a link in the
description and one up here now you know
whenever I see those Boston Dynamics
videos come out
I'm always simultaneously amazed at the
achievements that they've been able to
produce and simultaneously scared that
I'm watching the birth of the ancestors
of our future robot / overlords so yeah
I've got mixed feelings about this but I
think it's a really important topic and
that's why I wanted to share this clip
with you and I also wanted to highlight
the fine work of the guys over at pin
decks so yeah definitely check them out
and for those of you who are asking
Derrick what about your videos why
haven't you been posting very much
lately well I have been working on some
stuff in fact I've got a full-length
90-minute documentary coming out in the
summer of this year it'll be available
globally so watch out for that I will be
giving you some updates closer to the
day and I also have a pilot for a brand
new series that I worked on with
minutephysics in minute earth I will put
a link in the description and if you're
in the u.s. you can go check it out
other places are geo blocked I you know
I can't say anything for that but it's
our intention to try to get the series
out to as many people around the world
as we possibly can so if you can't check
it out go and do that now and I will be
posting some more videos soon I promise
and hopefully it will explain why I've
been absent for some of this time so
yeah I hope you enjoyed that clip